this morning in our Saturday session
William Patrick Corrigan for more than
20 years he's been the frontman of the
Smashing Pumpkins one of the most
popular bands of all time but he's also
released two solo albums the most recent
just this month we'll hear him perform
in just a moment but first we spoke with
William at the Gibson guitar showroom
here in New York
[Music]
he was Billy when we first came to know
him Billy Corgan the intense frontman of
all rocks Smashing Pumpkins in the early
90s he was a kid from the Chicago
suburbs on a mission I really wanted out
what did you want out of suburban
malaise strip malls the pedantic sort of
structure of middle-class life
[Music]
Corgan saw music as his escape hatch and
everyone told me you're wrong can't you
can't possibly do this you don't have
the talent you don't have the voice no
one makes it look at your father he
didn't make it my father was a musician
but he wasn't wrong his band broke
through in 1993 with the album Siamese
Dream the follow-up Mellon Collie and
the infinite sadness went to number one
and sold more than 10 million copies in
the US alone when you had success were
you surprised by I know it sounds
terribly ungrateful but now I wasn't
surprised at all in fact my mother told
me she wasn't surprised 1%
where did her faith come from you'd have
to ask her see that goes on the list of
things I wished I'd asked my mother
Corgan lost his mother to cancer in 1996
when you lose somebody quite young you
know you look back and say oh I just I
wish I knew a little bit more about this
one thing it's like shadows so I have to
guess to what degree is is your music an
attempt to fill in shadows it's an
interesting question I think my music is
an attempt to reflect the inner world
that I feel and that I believe in but I
see very little representation outwardly
which is a bit strange it's like Wizard
of Oz
[Music]
Horgan's new record Oh Jill Allah is his
first solo album in more than a decade
and Billy has become William Patrick
Courtney you just decided you didn't
want to be Billy anymore was that I just
started to feel uncomfortable and became
kind of a weird like a sign of my
arrogance or something and so once I saw
that it irritated people and I thought
okay I'm definitely gonna do this you
liked irritating I'd like irritating
people yeah and he's quite good at it
espousing free speech and conspiracy
theories on controversial talk shows
once we give up s-- free speech in this
country it is over I'm a natural
contrarian you like pushing back I just
think the world's a little too
comfortable for itself for its own good
we need clowns we need weirdos we need
freaks they keep the system in check
Corgan says he tried to walk away from
music but discovered he couldn't ended
up pulling on an acoustic guitar and
sort of starting over and saying well if
I can prove to myself that I can still
write a good song then there's a reason
to continue working with producer Rick
Rubin the songs took shape yeah it's
totally from the cosmos yeah that feel
pretty good I'm suspicious which means
it felt good you just didn't like to
feel like there you go see your figure
you're figuring it out now